hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was suggested to me by
so many of you and uh as usual i know by
the number of suggestions just how crazy
the game will be
uh it's a game between vietnamese
international master juan min
also a member of the croatia bulldogs
team led by uh viacom malfoy and i'm
just kidding
by vehicles of nimitz uh and daniel
naradicki
and i'm not gonna be uh you know
attributing any immortal titles to to
this game or
i know you guys don't enjoy that because
there are too many games played today
and you know every game every day could
be like an immortal game so you guys
decide whether this
uh you know can be can be such a game
but uh
uh it's not not even relevant uh because
this game is so incredible
i'm sure you guys are gonna enjoy it so
uh without further ado let's check it
out uh
uh we have d4 uh by meanley
uh and d6 by daniel uh so we have
uh knight to f3 and bishop to g4 daniel
goes for the weighted defense
we have bishop to f4 sort of a london
london setup
and now knight to d7 we have knight b to
d2
and knight g to f6 now so just nicely
continuing development we have h3
challenging this bishop
and now you could either capture or go
back we have bishop back to h5
and now c3 strengthening the center and
also preparing queen b3 to
develop the queen with tempo so here c6
and the queen to b3 now and daniel
counters the queen with queen to b6 now
white can either choose to trade queens
or do something else and it's almost
uh never a good idea to trade queens in
positions like these because
you don't really gain anything and
trading without gaining anything isn't
the way to go and there are some
positions uh
there are some games that reach this
exact same position where e3 was played
but here we have
e4 and it is now only as of move eight
that we have a completely new game so
let's see
how black deals with this with bishop
captures on f3
g captures on f3 voluntarily ruining the
pawn structure but also
improving the structure in the center
here and you kind of want to
use the g file for attack if black
decides to castle king side at any point
so e5 striking in the center we have
bishop back to e3 makes sense now the
threat is just
captures as this will expose uh the
queen to the bishop
and the queen back to c7 we have f4 now
uh striking in the center and bishop to
e7 now preparing the castle king side
and here white plays rook to g1 kind of
trying to
discourage black from castle and kings
and maybe create some further weaknesses
by movies like g6
but this is exactly what daniel goes for
he castles king's side and he's not
afraid of any captures
bishop or bishop h6 ideas uh as you'll
see
uh what happened so here f captures an
e5 making room for the bishop to come to
h6 put pressure
on the g7 pawn d captures on e5 and now
bishop the h6 threatening to pick up
the the g7 pawn we have knights the e8
now nicely defending this and also
making room for the f pawn to be pushed
and now knight to f3 i'm bringing
another attacker into the game
uh we have came to h8 on pinning now g
captures on h6
becomes a possibility and bishop back to
e3 now
we have knight to d6 now adding a an
attacker to the e4 pawn
and queen to c2 just nicely defending
and now
f5 and all of a sudden you can see that
it's actually black who's pushing
and it's a white king that's still in
the center of the board so let's see
what happens here
d captures on e5 knight captures an e4
and now
finally castles by white he goes for a
queen side castles
and now knight captures an e5 grabbing
that pawn in the center
uh knight captures queen captures and
here just bishop to d4 and if here if uh
if daniel did not have this a queen to
f4 check move
uh it would be game over because you
lose the g7 pawn and that's just it so
quintet for check is the only move
king to b1 and now bishop to f6
countering the light square
the uh white's dark square bishop uh
bishop back to e3 attacking the queen
and queen to h4 now and now
a very nice rook left with rook to d7
putting more pressure on g7
for the moment the g7 point is nicely
defended but now if something like
bishop to d4 comes could be problematic
for black
and also the b7 pawn is hanging however
rook 8 to d8 we have to get rid of that
rook
either by by forcing him to move or by
trading
so here rook captures on b7 it's not a
problem daniel wants to use the b
file for attacking purposes so rook to
b8
now offering a rook trade and now you
could move the rook somewhere like rook
to b3 let's say or you could trade here
here uh we have rook captures on b8
rook captures and now this is the moment
that you've all been waiting for
uh now you can see that there's a lot of
pressure on white's queen uh king's
queen son uh the king is uh occupies the
b file same as the rook
and there's a lot of pressure on this c3
pawn so you can imagine if something
like this happens
you will not be able to capture back
because well uh
because of this so here you have to move
the king and a move like king the c1 is
what
should have been played here however uh
miller played uh
king to a1 and this simply will not do
here we have knight captures on c3 right
away
and it seems like uh another the
greatest of moves because now the knight
can be captured and this is exactly what
minla does so be captures on c3
but now comes the move or rather a
series of moves while we're even showing
this game uh feel free to pause the
video and
win this game for black while i give you
a couple of seconds and you know
go go for the craziest idea possible
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting
the uh absolutely uh crazy queen to a4
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show this is what uh
daniel played and this is not only uh an
incredible move because the queen cannot
be captured but it's an incredible move
because of what
follows this uh well queen that cannot
be captured
so the problem is if you capture then
okay the rook is cutting off
the king from the b file just bishop
captures and c3 is checkmate there's
obviously that
and even if you don't do that after
queen to a4 you could do something like
bishop to d3
uh try and defend the queen doesn't
matter we're just going to trade
captures captures and again bishop
captures on c3 is checkmate so
that's out of the question so here after
queen to a4 you don't really have a good
move you have to play something but you
know
it's uh it's it doesn't really matter
what you play uh queen to c1 is what was
played in the game
but now comes the second pause the video
moment as it's now now it's actually
to check made in three moves so feel
free to pause the video and you know try
to find
a similar idea again while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on psych
well rather than trying to sacrifice the
queen for the second time and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's queen to d1 and this is just
this is just amazing uh now there's
nothing
there's nothing you can do here it was
in this position that tuamin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh so really really crazy stuff of
course if you capture the queen you've
again
uh removed the queen from the defense of
the c3 pawn so this is just checkmate
and even if you don't do this if you try
something else let's say you try bishop
to d2 or something like that i mean it
doesn't really matter
there's no way to defend you're just
going to play bishop captures on c3
the queen is pinned the bishop now has
the move and now queen characters will
be checkmate so it doesn't matter what
white does uh this is just just
incredible stuff so
uh just once again after this b captures
on c3
we can just uh look at this like knight
captures b captures and now in
super slow motion look at this queen to
a4
outstanding queen c1 and then comes
queen to d1 this is
wow this is really really really
insane stuff and you know yeah it's like
uh it's like that uh
hikaru's immortal queen game where he
just you know tries to
sacrifice his queen and it you know it
simply cannot be captured if you haven't
seen it i will put a link to it in the
description below first thing you'll see
so do check it out it's quite quite an
amazing game
uh so yeah congratulations to daniel
naradiski once again for creating a
masterpiece he does
seem to create these kind of games quite
often uh
with the black pieces i do think he's
one of the if not
the most exciting player to watch
nowadays uh so i think we can expect
more brilliancies like this this from
him and uh one other uh interesting uh
thing about this game uh black played
this with a 98 98.8 percent accuracy so
the entire game is basically
perfectly played uh and i will uh
include a link to this game if you also
want to check out the link to the
official game it was played on chess.com
so you can you know go through it
yourself if you guys are interested in
that
uh so yeah and of course congratulations
to both of these players as it always
requires
uh two players to create uh to create a
masterpiece uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank max waldbaum
uh stanley hickman david kimura see
visceras and kevin wade for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
of course whatever else happens in the
chess world uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do check out
the the game in the description below if
you still haven't uh see you soon